guess what the minimalists are going on
tour with a live version of the
minimalists podcast
and i want to invite you to join us for
a night of less find your nearest city
at the minimalists comm slash tour we'll
see you there how do I lose weight in a
healthy way is a carnivore diet gonna
help me do that because that's where I'm
at right now like I want to I want to be
a little bit leaner like when I
snowboard it's a lot easier for me to
like control myself when I don't have an
extra 15 pounds hanging around the other
thing I want to talk about too is what
unhealthy meats do you recommend people
don't eat sure or animal products cuz
like egg yolks versus egg whites and
then also what if there was like say
your top three vegetables or your top
three plant-based things like okay if
you're gonna eat plant-based things
these are the only three things you
should eat like what would those be and
you could start with any of that okay
right you guys love just hammering yeah
man let me just give you a firehose of
question it's like jeopardy man it's
like okay this is but this is go pod get
to choose win we'll talk about okay so
weight loss I think at a basic level
boils down to calories and calories out
right like I could technically lose
weight on a Twinkie diet if I absolutely
could lose weight at sweet height what
what that equation misses is that the
food you eat affects your satiety you go
and the more nutrient dense the food you
eat is the more satiated you're going to
be and the more enjoyable it's going to
be the loose weight and the more
sustainable it's going to be to keep it
off yes right wife I just the rice I'm
hungry an hour later exactly no
micronutrients no micronutrients and
rice and it's for pure carbohydrates so
it's not really going to affect you
could lose weight just eating rice right
right but as we suggested right just
eating rice isn't going to lead to some
major nutrient deficiencies in the short
term even quickly right so I believe
that the way to lose weight sustainably
is to create satiety the human body is
programmed over four million years of
hominid evolution to never stay in a
prison of calorie restriction to never
stay without micronutrients right that's
not an evolutionary good thing for us
ocean air only goodness that is
starvation you don't want that right
right so if you die it by simply
limiting calories
Weight Watchers etc hmm you're going to
fail unfortunately the majority time we
fail because that is millions of years
of evolution saying you can do it
short-term but eventually you got
sustainable your body's gonna break out
of that prison yes
so I think that a carnivore diet could
be very helpful for you you give your
body the most nutrient rich foods you
create satiety
I'm not saying carbohydrates are bad I'm
saying that for a lot of people
carbohydrates can affect satiety
negatively and where are the
micronutrients in the carbohydrates as
Josh is saying for some people a small
amount of carbohydrates at certain times
can be helpful but we talked a little
bit about key to those ketosis and
ketogenic diets or low carb diets I'm
not saying low carb diets are the only
way to lose weight but they are a very
effective way for a lot of people
because they improve satiety
one of the things we know about ketones
is that they affect society in a
positive way meaning we are less hungry
yeah when you develop that electrical
engine you can tap into all of the fat
on your body that's what gets burned at
a high level basically I'm gonna ketosis
right okay you tap into this really big
gas tank that you've got the muscle
glycogen gas tank is about 2,000
calories small gas tank right
okay carbohydrate gas tank real small
electrical quote gas tank real big okay
we've all got 20,000 calories 30,000
calories of fat on our body mmm-hmm
which is what we will do in terms of
starvation well being on a low carb diet
kind of taps into that you're more
satiated between meals you can go longer
amounts time between meals and it's
easier to limit the calories you consume
it puts you in less of a sort of satiety
prison so what I'm hearing you say Paul
is you I need to the reason why
carnivore would help me is because I'm
gonna feel satiated and that's going to
tap into some fuels that I'm not used to
burning but it's also it's not starving
myself it but it is still taking in well
the equation of losing weight is taking
in less calories and what you put out
exactly okay the other piece of that
equation that is often missed is that
the foods you eat can affect calories
out the foods you eat appear to be able
to affect your metabolism this is hotly
debated right hotly debated okay but
there does appear to be a possibility
that your metabolism may incur
so you may burn more calories right okay
and if you look at overfeeding
experiments this is quite nuanced and
Tommy and I have talked about this many
times but it's pretty hard to get
someone to gain weight if they don't
have a combination of carbohydrates and
fat interesting we talked about this a
little earlier the combination of
carbohydrates and fat is an
evolutionarily rare thing there are not
many places where those occur together
that's what bodybuilders function best
when they're eating chicken and rice
basically or you know steak and rice but
they need that car because bodybuilding
is by the way an unnatural stack em but
carbohydrates in fat together ice cream
doughnuts breast milk that is uniquely
satiety preventing mmm
that sort of short-circuits our
mechanisms it says hey you're sucking on
a boob keep going you're gonna get real
fat like this is good for you right milk
is hard to stop eating cheese is hard to
stop eating so what is a very what is a
reasonable strategy for people to zhing
weight is to limit either fat or
carbohydrates we know that low-fat
high-carbohydrate diets can work for
weight loss interest and high fat low
carb diets can work for weight loss it's
a more difficult but doable to do
moderate carb moderate fat so it's
totally doable you just have to be a
little more disciplined and really be
appreciating that processed foods will
short-circuit your satiety mechanism so
the first thing for you is alcohol yeah
get rid of that cut away okay second
thing give it a processed foods don't
short-circuit your society mechanisms
your body is not going to stay in a
satiety prison it has not done it for 4
min it will not do it you will cheat
where things are processed than we
realized right yes sure so a lot of the
things we think of as as natural or
actually processed if it's got a label
if it's in a package it's probably
probably process might incur and then
thirdly you can certainly do a low carb
strategy like carnivore but you don't
have to